wir haben gerade schon gesagt ein
zeichen von misstrauen eigentlich dass
die meisten menschen sagen dabei wird es
jetzt nicht bleiben das wird schon
wieder weitergehen auch wenn uns gesagt
wird erstmal gilt das bis ende dezember
wir rechnen schon mit einem 44 längeren
lockdown da stoppt so kann man es aber
auch nicht stehen lassen weil die
sonderregelung für hot spots über das
war unter der gestern beschlossen worden
es kam daher die man überraschend
besteht hier ein papier ausdrücklich
drin und das ist ganz klar dass wir in
diesem besonders gefährdeten hotspots
dass wir dann mehr machen müssen als in
ganz deutschland das ist gar keine frage
und so hoffnung ist ja dass bis
weihnachten sehr viele dieser hot spots
nicht mehr wirklich diese sehr hohen
instanzen erreichen dass es ja auch der
russe gefährdend für jeden der erlebt
und wir hoffen einfach dass wir von
diesen zahlen runter kommen dann geld
noch aller regel natürlich die
einheitliche regeln wir haben es jetzt
hier gerade aktuell in berlin dass es
nicht ganz einfach zu verstehen aber wir
trotzdem bei weihnachten bleiben eine
der nächsten maßnahmen waren bezogen auf
den einzelhandel und zwar wie viel platz
da sein muss für jeden kunden und das
wird jetzt vor allem in der
weihnachtszeit dick doch schon schwierig
wie sinnvoll ist diese maßnahme sich wie
kann sie in der realität umgesetzt
werden denn man kann ja noch immer an
einem laden alle personen an einer
stelle haben wie soll das funktionieren
dass man dort auf die abstände achtet
und wie lange sollen die schlangen
draußen in der bitteren kälte jetzt
werden ja sieht man ein großer
unterschied ob man draußen steht oder
drinnen ist also wenn man drinnen ist
wurde es kommt die erosion übertragung
zustande und zeigt sich eben dass man
sich leider auch also in solchen
geschäften infizieren kann die studien
der letzten monate haben es nochmal klar
gezeigt insbesondere was nur in den
vereinigten staaten selbst wenn dann
maske trägt dann atmet man ja durch eine
art macht wird die sohle 1
und wenn der abstand dann zwei gewehre
lassen das aber es sind zu viele leute
drin dann ist die konzentration der
hochschule so hoch dass es dort zu also
ansteckungskette kommen kann
das wäre insbesondere dann für die
älteren gefährlich die man unmittelbar
nach dem shoppen besuchen sie amüsant
ganz simpel
heute geht man shoppen und zwei tage
darauf oder drei tage drauf besucht man
dann seine verwandten
kann man schon ansteckend zahlen das
wird man selbst gar nicht bemerken oder
am vierten tag beispielsweise wenn man
dann sehr stark ansteckend es infiziert
mal leute hat sich das aber beim einkauf
gut das wollen wir verhindern daher
diese regel sozial nichts vormachen das
macht das einkaufen nicht unattraktiver
wenn man jetzt im weihnachts shopping
lange vor der tür steht erst recht
wenn's kalt ist und da eben in langen
schlangen warten muss er lauterbach wie
sehr freuen sie sich als der
spd-politiker dass das vor allen dingen
amazon kräftig helfen wird gar nicht ich
freue mich gar nicht ist es auch eine
völlig falsche sicht der dinge dass wir
uns über irgendeine einschränkung also
die wir hier machen freuen und ich würde
mich einfach fahren denn die impfstoffe
gut wirken egal ich bin gebe es ja
diejenigen die sie ihren verlassen wolle
die haben übereinstimmen das hilft vor
allen dingen amazon das weiß ich nicht
ob das immer so hilft dass spekulation
aber es ist auf jeden fall so dass wir
nichts riskieren können wir können nicht
folgendes machen wir können nicht sagen
weil wir immer schon auch so nicht
helfen wollen gehen wir jetzt also in
die geschäfte ein und stecken uns an und
infizieren danach unsere eltern oder die
großeltern das können wir einfach nicht
machen
das kann nicht die lösung sein und daher
müssen wir schon aufeinander aufpassen
wenn wir jetzt dieses ganze corona ja
noch einmal ganz kurz für uns gepasst
ihren lassen finden sie nach dem ganzen
hin und her der regelung lockte und
wieder zurück dann der zweite locker und
jetzt sehr locker und verlängert in
berlin wieder an das hier lokal wieder
an das hin und her in den schulen usw
wie gut finden sie hat die regierung das
gemeistert welche note würden sie
ergeben
ich gebe keine noten also ich habe ja in
einigen dieser beschlüsse mitgearbeitet
und es war nicht meine art jemanden
noten zu geben dass man habe ich gemacht
als es dort der uni prof gewesen bin
jetzt nicht mehr und ich wissen wie
folgt sagen also insgesamt hat
deutschland in dieser partie einen weg
beschreiten können den andere länder als
erfolgreich betrachtet ich kann davon
ein liedchen singen
ich sage oft vor in ländern über
webinare natürlich wo es viel schlechter
gelaufen dass insbesondere in den
vereinigten staaten wo ich zehn jahre
gelebt aber nicht nur dort
ich glaube ich schon dass wir maßvoll
durchgegangen sind wir haben
wirtschaftlich jeden dem genommen aber
weniger als viele andere länder
und wir haben eine relativ geringe
sterblichkeit im fielen im vergleich zu
vielen anderen nennen obwohl wir eine
sehr alte bevölkerung habe und das ist
schon eine leistung
eigentlich hätten wir bei der sehr alten
bevölkerung in deutschland hätten wir
mit einer der höchsten sterblichkeit und
wenn dich die höchste sterblichkeit in
europa erwarten müssen
danke an den spd-gesundheitsexperten
karl lauterbach
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei der schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren